it will forever go down in history is
probably the hardest
sequence i've ever had to film hollywood
may seem like a dream for many
but a lot of the times behind the glitz
and glam are actors struggling to even
get through a scene
what the cast and crew of tv series and
movies have to go through in order to
get their work to the big screen
is absolutely unimaginable from harsh
filming conditions
strict diets that include dehydration
and life-changing stunts
you're about to be surprised at just how
many of the hardest movie scenes were
caught on camera
what was the hardest scene to shoot with
me audio scenes
tom holland may have struggled with
keeping details of his marvel movies
under wraps but
on set he has an entire crew to help
make sure the public doesn't even catch
a glimpse of what they're filming
however this can make filming extremely
difficult for the actors
when tom and zendaya filmed their date
scene and walked across the bridge
once the director called cut they'd have
to dash to hide in a tiny tent away from
the public eye
and then we had to come back out and
then it got really late and there's like
a football game or something
doing this over and over again had tom
and zendaya absolutely exhausted
millie bobby brown filmed some of the
toughest scenes of her life on the set
of stranger things season 3.
remember how cool it looked when eleven
was spinning into the void trying to
contact billy
it may have looked awesome behind the
scenes as well but it was a difficult
few hours for millie
luckily her adorable instagram post let
us know having billy's actor daker
montgomery by her side made the process
a little more bearable euphoria is a
trippy experience for the viewer and the
filming behind the scenes made the
experience the same for zendaya
except way more physically demanding
during the party scene where roo gets
highly intoxicated you might
have thought that the room spinning was
all done with a green screen but zendaya
actually had to film in a spinning room
check out the behind the scenes
everything is just spinning and you have
no
sense of where the real world is zendaya
admitted this was one of the most
difficult scenes to film because she had
no perception of direction
and had to make sure she stayed in
character it actually sounds
kind of scary bridgeton isn't what you
would call
an action-packed show but filming the
dance scenes were brutal
the cast weren't professional dancers
which meant they endured six weeks of
intense dance practice
but no amount of practice prepared them
for how challenging it was to perform
intricate steps and dialogue at the same
time
actress phoebe dinevor said it was quite
difficult to pull off
you are a bridget there is nothing you
cannot do
celebrities may spend their down time
lounging in penthouses and luxury homes
but on the set of movies like the hunger
games they're splashing around sewers
seriously it was a brutal three weeks
for the filming of the sewer sequence in
mockingjay part two they filmed in an
actual sewer that was painfully hot to
add to how gross
it must have been after a few hours liam
hemsworth's very absorbent costume
weighed over 20 pounds
restricting his ability to even act out
the scene
very physically demanding very
emotionally demanding
who didn't want to be a part of
dumbledore's army well when you hear how
uncomfortable filming on the room of
requirement set was
you might just change your mind you've
done it neville
you've found the room of requirement the
phelp twins and bonnie wright had a
whole lot to say
about their difficult experience while
shooting the fifth film
i've never told anyone this but i hated
the room of requirement
set the set was apparently small hot and
very cramped making the conditions less
than ideal
bonnie even said she experienced
hysteria from a claustrophobic attack
we bet they were wishing they could
actually disapperate somewhere else at
that moment
we all know robert pattinson has some
very strong feelings about his time
on twilight and to be fair he put up
with quite a bit of what some people
would probably call ridiculousness
however he finally reached his breaking
point when it came to renesmee's birth
scene in breaking dawn
he claims having to actually bite
through a weird prosthetic that was
covered in fake blood
was the hardest scene he filmed in the
entire franchise
i think that was the major the major
factor
we just have one word to say about that
ew
getting to film in hungary might seem
like a dream but the shadow and bone
cast are admitting that
while it was beautiful a lot of the time
it was rough
most of the weather conditions you see
going on in the show were a hundred
percent real
especially the sleet and thunderstorms
now imagine having to spend hours on end
enduring these conditions pretty uh
pretty terrifying
actors danielle galligan and callahan
skogman said the cherry on top was
having to film in a cold water tank
during these conditions
cherry deals with much heavier content
than tom holland is used to filming for
marvel
which made the whole process of filming
the movie difficult
the war scenes in particular are very
overwhelming and require so many pieces
to fit together
needless to say tom was challenged and
said this
role took me to some of the darkest
places i have ever been
emotionally physically anythingly he
even
almost broke his nose while filming so
i'm yeah i'm really really proud of this
movie
the after series is steamy but behind
the scenes
we guess you can say the steaminess
evaporates
we all know this iconic lake scene
between tessa and hardin right
well for actor hiro finds tiffin that
scene was
suffocating literally he wasn't able to
touch the floor in the lake which meant
he was struggling to keep afloat and
not drown while also trying to give his
best performance
you think that's weird no
if they sound a little out of breath
during the scene it's because they were
in the end many toe cramps later they
managed to get it done
we've heard of actors having to go on
strict diets to get in shape for a film
but for this role in the witcher henry
cavill had to dehydrate himself
you heard us the actor essentially gave
up water for four days in order to film
shirtless scenes
like this one in the bathtub it's a very
iconic moment
supposedly it helped him seem like he
had more muscle definition
it got so bad by the fourth day that he
said he could actually smell nearby
water
i was surprised that i still existed
just watching the battle of the bastards
in game of thrones was
tense but for kit harington it was one
of the most
challenging scenes he ever had to shoot
in his role as jon snow
they had to rehearse the scene for weeks
because the battle was one long
continuous take
which means everything had to go
perfectly
as you could imagine it took hours and
hours we're exhausted just thinking
about it
it feels good to be alive sometimes it
isn't wild set locations or epic stunts
that make things
difficult to film sometimes it's just
baking
we're sorry to burst your bubble but to
all the boys lara jean
is far from a good baker in real life
lana condor has explained how difficult
those baking scenes were for her
because she had no experience in order
to get through it they had to hire a
professional baker to stand next to her
and instruct her on what to do and how
to do it
just so it could pass as convincing on
screen
it was a educational experience
you'd assume that the hard scenes to
film for brie larson and captain marvel
would be some intense stunts
but that couldn't be further from the
truth her most challenging scenes were
the ones she had to film with her furry
friend
goose great team partner gave a lot brie
is highly allergic to cats
so you can just imagine how she must
have been filming on those days
but brie was able to find humor in the
situation it was kind of like the
ongoing joke that like
i would do like crazy wire work stunts
but then the cat showed up on set and i
was like
we need to have a plan i'd be like
stressed out like washing my hands a
million times
believe it or not the actual heist
scenes in money heist were a piece of
cake to film for the actors in
comparison to their season 3 adventure
on a boat
they were filming in the middle of an
ocean in thailand
in weather that was excruciatingly hot
the mix of high waves and blazing sun
had the cast getting sick
over the side of the boat actor miguel
eran even had a heat stroke by the end
of it
we won't even touch on how awkward
filming the fifty shades of grey films
must have been but we're going to
discuss
what dakota johnson is claiming as one
of the toughest scenes to film
the elevator scene the elevator was
filled with the extras we see in the
final cut
but behind the cameras were 50 crew
members all confined to the tiny space
where dakota and jamie dornan got
quite intimate it is a kind of bizarre
experience andrew lincoln's first scene
of the entire walking dead series ended
up being his most
difficult to film it's the moment where
rick is faced with having to take down a
little zombie girl
that's when i realized this is going to
be the greatest job of my career but
also
the most painful this emotionally
bothered him so much that after a few
takes he was so distressed and
physically
needed to stop talk about nauseating
just what did leonardo dicaprio have to
go through in order to finally win an
oscar
well his time filming the revenant
wasn't pretty and it's difficult to pick
just one challenging thing he had to
endure on camera
from having to eat raw liver film with a
real bear and develop hypothermia
we're going to say leo wins for having
the most difficult time on set
i've never quite seen anything
cinematically like that
watching saul being kidnapped and forced
to dig his own grave was dark but behind
the scenes it was also grim
not only for saul's actor bob odenkirk
but for jesse and walt's actors brian
cranston and aaron paul
as well it was absolutely freezing on
location
and the winds were so strong the dirt
around them was blowing straight into
their faces
check out what walt had to say about the
scene i'm supposed to hold the gun out
and i'm so cold that i'm
shaking and i'm like oh my god that was
probably the toughest scene to do
he knew what he was talking about
charlize theron and zoe kravitz had a
lot to say about being on the set of mad
max including that filming the movie was
one of the hardest things they've ever
done
they were filming in conditions that
included extreme heat
beating sun dust storms and days that
went
way beyond your average eight hour work
day by the end of filming the cast was
exhausted from the difficult action
choreography
and dangerous car chases we don't blame
them
it was really fun who knew being an
actor could get this difficult
it's hard to believe how much the cast
and crew of these projects endured
just to bring us our favorite tv series
and films
we know they're getting paid really well
for their work but is it worth it
what do you think thanks for watching